من اجل دخول مدينه بخموت وبسبب احتدام
المعارك في محيطها اضطررنا لسلوك الطرق
التفافيه واعره بين القرى المحيطه
بالمدينه
بصعوبه تمكنا من دخول بعض احياء بخموت
رصبات جانبا من الدمار الذي لحق باجزاء
واسعه من مبانيها ومؤسساتها وبنيتها
التحتيه
هذا هو المستشفى الجديد للمدينه الذي
افتتح قبل الحرب بفتره وجيزه
ميخائيل يصف الوضع في مخموت بانه جحيم
حقيقي لكنه واحد من نحو ثلاثه الاف شخص ما
زالوا يرفضون مغادره المدينه التي كان
يسكنها نحو 70 الفا
اريد ان ارحل لكن جارتي مريضه وعمرها 83
عاما هي وحيده ولا تستطيع الحركه لا
يمكنني تركها الوضع سيء وخطير جدا هنا ما
يحدث شيء فظيع قد نقتل في اي لحظه
هذا الملجا اصبح يمثل نقطه حياه لمخموت
التي ظلت محرومه من كل اساسيات الحياه
لنحو خمسه اشهر عاشتها تحت القصف المستمري
والسعي الروسي المتواصل للسيطره عليها
املنا في الجيش الاوكراني
لا ادري لماذا يحاصرنا الروس ويدمرون
الاسواق والصيدليات اشعر بالامان ابلغ من
العمر 90 عاما لقد نجوت من الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والان اعيش هذه الحرب
دخوله بعض احيائي مدينه بخموت اصبح يوصف
بانه خطوه انتحاريه خطوات روسيه تهاجم
المدينه من ثلاثه محاور في محاوله
لتطويقها
فاميليشياتو فاقنار التي تقود معارك الجيش
الروسي على جبهه بخموت نجحت في دخول
الاحياء الشرقيه للمدينه كما تمكنت من قطع
الطريق السريع بين مخموت وسلافيانسك في
المحور الشمالي الشرقي واحرز التقدما
كبيرا في الجنوب بهدف قطع الطريق
الاستراتيجي بين بخموت وكسستانتينيكا
بينما بقيه الطرق الالتفافيه عبر مدينه
تشافيار سالكه نحو المدينه
يؤكد الاوكرانيون دائما قدرتهم على صد
الهجمات الروسيه
وان اعترفوا بصعوبه المعارك في ظل التحشيد
الضخم المستمر للقوات الروسيه على هذا
المحور امر في الجزيره ضخمود